[Applause]
he is the host of cnn's fareed zakaria
gps and author of the new book ten
lessons for a post-pandemic world for
read zakaria is over here
i i was i was so uh
tempted by habit to lunge at you
from india this is a perfectly nice
substance okay so i
read your book in one big gobble it's
great great read quick read
and also like right out of the day's
headlines
i mean it's about the pandemic right
very gutsy to write a book
before the thing is over right and they
call it a post-pandemic world
well yeah because we see in europe it's
the
pandemic's coming back in the fall this
thing is far from over
do you worry about that that you're that
something's going to happen that
you know be like oh boy i should have
waited well i think
no i think i've got it about right in
the sense of what i'm talking about
is we now understand this
you know these problems in a way that we
didn't because this is not going to be
the last pandemic
and one of the things i talk about in
the book is
this should be a wake-up call to realize
we've been living
in a way that is very risky you know if
you think about the way in which
we are spewing carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and eating
the way we eat the failure i talk about
the factory farms
factory forms are essentially a petri
dish yes for the next pandemic
you're just going to create larger and
larger more powerful viruses
the way we subsidize people to live at
the edges of forests
so you know so i feel as though we've
got you know
and it's like we're driving the fastest
race car in the world and we're like who
needs seat belts
who needs insurance but but you know
that
what you're really saying is we need to
learn yeah i
i don't know if we're the learn species
really
i mean my question to you is do you i
i hate to say this because it sounds so
pessimistic but i don't think one is
gonna do it
in other words one pandemic i don't
think we're gonna change
after one i think i think we're it's
gonna take more than one
because people are just going to go oh
that was a fluke thank god 2020 is over
we're back to normal i don't see less
cheeseburgers being eaten well
take a look at what hap has happened in
east asia you know really these are the
countries that have handled the pandemic
the best
uh south korea singapore hong kong
taiwan more than any
also the thinnest well but so part of it
is yes they don't have
the obesity problem which is you're
absolutely right a kind of
disease multiplier but they all went
through sars and mers
and they did badly many of them taiwan
actually handled it not so well
it was a worse and they learned and they
learned from it and they
revamped their public health systems
they just they moved early and
aggressively they figured out how to do
contact tracing
you know so you can learn now here's the
tragedy
taiwan has handled this better than
anyone else in my view 24 million people
uh in the country seven deaths you know
to give your sense new york state
20 million people right 34 000 deaths
now
what the taiwanese did was they used
they never did a lockdown bill
they it was smart contact tracing uh
testing
you know occasionally very selective
closures
but they use good technology phones but
they used it well
all this stuff was invented in america
the technology was invented in america
the software was invented in america the
guy
running the taiwan response was educated
at johns hopkins
so they have taken our secret sauce and
we're watching
while they're getting it right and we're
foundering
again i agree with all that but you're
mentioning
one half of the equation in my view the
external part
there's the internal part your immune
system
fighting it internally because viruses
are everywhere
and you can't avoid them and externally
you need to do both
they were successful because of both
because they're healthier internally and
what i object so much about what this
country did yes trump of course [ __ ]
it up we expect that
but the people the the people like dr
fauci and those those folks who are the
medical assistant they never once had
the courage
to ask the people to get themselves
in better health as the best way to
ensure this they're cowards
they are cowards they will not ask for
that little bit of sacrifice
i agree with you but i'll tell you one
part of the problem is
we have a health care system that is so
broken and it is particularly broken
for poorer people because i saw a really
interesting study
which pointed out that you know germans
were a lot healthier than americans and
even though germans are
very rich and they have you know they
they have a diet that is not completely
ideal
the big difference was in germany your
annual visit to the doctor
is free because you know it's universal
healthcare
and at your annual visit to the doctor
the doctor always tells you four or five
things
like don't smoke don't be overweight
exercise put your seat belts on when you
drive those
just those constant reminders actually
play an incredibly large role in your
ultimate
health outcomes but we don't have we
have lots of millions and millions of
people who don't go to the doctor
because they can't afford it don't have
access to good food i mean that has to
be part of the solution
you